bastien chenu porte parole du
rassemblement national ancien
maire-adjoint de beauvais sébastien
chenu bonsoir bon toi alors peut-être
votre première réaction notamment après
cette victoire a trait à perpignan louis
aliot est remixé des îles avis qu'on
essaie surtout la fin de ce qui était
appelé le front républicain cette espèce
de pacotille et consorts à chaque
élection 1 qui a vocation à des gens qui
eux en différentes étiquettes politiques
oublient leurs convictions les teasers
et des remises de parler re pour pouvoir
faire barrage à gaza parce qu'en plus
des électeurs de perpignan ont décidé
que le front républicain n'était pas
acceptable que c'était une magouille
politique elle démarche pluie
aujourd'hui national en même temps
qu'ils font perpignan a su ainsi un smur
on l'a vu fort taux d'abstention à près
de 60% c'est historique c'est favorable
à votre parti oui sinon c'est surtout
défavorable à la démocratie cette
abstention elle ne tombe pas du ciel en
réalité le gouvernement nous a démontré
non seulement qu'il était incapable
d'organiser dans de long terme une
élection municipale
l'abstention était un des marqueurs qui
permet de dire si cette élection est
réussi ou pas aux raids ne l'est pas
démocratiquement parlant de l'autre côté
ça ne tombe pas du ciel dans le sens où
les français sont écoeurés des
politiques qui sont menées et surtout se
détournent des urnes parce que sinon
sentiment d'avoir été trahis par
emmanuel macron par son gouvernement
ce qui leur avait promis la sécurité qui
voit le produit ni la souveraineté qui
leur avait promis à tâtonner cet échec
sanitaires économiques sociales qui est
celui des hôtels bas qu'on est bien
il invite les françaises détourner des
urnes pour vous c'est un vote sanction
quelque sorte pour le parti présidentiel
abbas ce soir évidemment le parti
présidentiel prend une claque magistrale
des requins d'hérouville on ne peut pas
dire que la 8e marche a gagné une ville
zéro ville gagner des villes
perdu surtout lorsqu'il son allié
américain
oui c'est par votre sanction pour la
république en marche
c'est aussi une chanson pour les
républicains qui perd des grandes villes
marseille bordeaux toulouse et cetera
qui auront été la plupart du temps allié
mais elle va compliquer ans ou si c'est
politique c'est en tous les cas une
sanction pour la politique qui est menée
par emmanuel macron et ceux qui le
soutiennent alors sébastien chenu on
lisait forte poussée des écologistes ce
soir qu'est ce que ça révèle pour vous
cette poussée verte
je crois que les électeurs il ya tant de
choses
ils attendent d'abord de la sécurité de
la souveraineté être protéger leur
identité leur sécurité et datant d'aussi
que soient prises en compte leurs
demandes d'écologie de localisme et
qu'on en finisse avec ce mondialisme qui
a fait fabriquer en coupe du monde
des éléments qui sont vendus ici en
français bien puisqu'il ne trouve pas
ces deux réponses
la sécurité et le localisme dans la
politique de la macro il se tourne vers
ce qui a perpignan on vend leur répondre
sur la sécurité dans une ville qui en a
bien besoin ils votent pour le
rassemblement national et vont se
tourner vers des écologistes mais dans
d'autres villes où les problématiques
environnementales sont importantes et
bien voilà c'est parce que cette
élection veux dire c'est qu'il ya des
demandes fortes dans le pays elles ne
sont pas satisfaites et qu'on est en
train de dessiner un nouveau clivage
demain d'un clivage entre le
rassemblement national et puis
probablement les verts merci sébastien
chenu d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes porte parole du
rassemblement national